let's pull up this next story from law
and crime aclu sues alabama attorney
general over devastating new law making
medical care for transgender youth a
felony it's a lie i love how they call
it care yeah that's awesome i i know
right right off the bat uh we also have
this out of missouri missouri proposes
legislation to prohibit gender
transitions for minors
um
yeah this is important thing here they
call it medical care
and um i think there's a framing issue
here that at the very least suggest this
country is totally fractured under um
by moral framework medical care to the
left is a 12 year old biological male
says i don't feel right so they say okay
we're going to give you surgeries which
could you know permanently alter damage
your body or restrict your body in some
way that we we we do that for only
gender ideology based circumstances well
and abortion
well so you know what what i mean is on
the right it's very clear this is
child abuse yeah on the left it's
affirmation and medical care the issue i
take with this is just um if if a 12
year old boy said i'm dysmorphic and i
need to cut my hand off
we would not say well for the sake of
the child we'll remove their hand but we
are seeing young women get double
mastectomies uh at
uh even at the age of 13 in some
circumstances we had i posted a study on
twitter about it so i i do want to point
out that framing but then just you know
generally open up the conversation to
what we're seeing with these uh you know
these states that are banning this and
then there are other states that are
going the other direction yeah you have
to define your terms
medical care specific like medical care
is is a thing it's a specific thing and
medical care is is something that is
done to treat
um a problem in the body it's to treat a
disease or a malformation or a lesion or
something like that and so then the
question is
is
is is puberty
a disease that has to be treated that's
the and that that's essentially what
we're hearing from the trans ideology
side of this they say that well you know
you the child that didn't consent to
puberty and so you have to put a puberty
blocker well puberty is not it's not a
disease it's a natural process in the
body well it's not just the body i mean
hormones wash over the brain and that's
how your brain becomes you know more
fully developed that's part of it as
well that's part of puberty is becoming
an adult it's not just a bodily
thing it's also yeah i mean it's the the
body of the brain as well yeah and so
this is horrible framing these people
are obviously perfectly happy to be
misunderstood as implying this is a law
which would say that a kid could not
receive a necessary procedure to save
their life because they're transgender
that's how this is framed what it should
say is
in alabama you are not allowed to give
children sex changes for some reason
some perverts are mad about that so uh
the interesting thing about medical care
is that i wonder uh does medical care in
a general sense include psychotherapy
well yeah well let me let me let me okay
can i make a point on that real fast i
just was just a simple question answer
is yes we all agree and then my point
was in scandinavian countries they don't
do child sex changes they do
psychotherapy but in the united states
they argue that's conversion therapy and
wrong and shouldn't be allowed well i
was just going to say that the problem
we're seeing today is has nothing to do
with science and i think we should have
seen back in the day when uh the
humanities were usurped educationally it
wasn't by by accident we'd make fun of
them like oh do you want to go take a
class to where you discuss how you feel
about an author's book in the american
dream in great gatsby or do you want to
study engineering not realizing that the
great thinkers and the ideologues the
people who study the humanities and
create these ideas the philosophers etc
that are out there and even people that
study english as we as we look down upon
them they took a hold of the subjects
that we disregarded and they changed the
language they actually from from the
ground up have redefined the ability to
define terms the average person doesn't
know what science is they don't really
understand engineering but they can read
a news article written for a fourth
grade level reader and so i i was
talking to a transgender antifa we
talked about this earlier a trans tifa
uh and satanist on on uh tick tock live
and the key thing is here and i noticed
this with every argument all we're
battling over then is words so we mock
english teachers like oh it's just
english went to school for english well
currently the battle isn't actually in
science it's english it's defining
actually our dictionary and what words
mean in terminology even biology is
mostly just built up of terms and i mean
yes latin and whatnot but i asked him i
go i go the guy goes you know
legitimately there is fascistic genocide
of trans people all around this country
and you're defending it and i go
fascistic genocide where in the world do
you see fascistic genus i'm i said i
want to know because you're china well
nobody what do you said this time
of trans kids that's almost like pets
right now but uh the recipe is shanghai
but he goes but he goes yeah and i go
where is this who goes oh well in the
texas laws i'm in texas i'm very
familiar with the texas trans laws right
now and there's no genocide happening so
he goes on to define and goes genocide i
said what is genocide man what is that
and that's what we have to ask him what
do you mean now by genocide because we
have no absolute truth he goes well
you know that that's taking kids away
from parent parents who who want to get
you know gender reaffirming surgery and
hormone therapy and you know and i'm
like that's weird for me because i
thought genocide involved killing and
all the genocidal maniacs and tyrants
over the years apparently wasted a lot
of resources they could have just you
see you know child protective services
and took the kids away for two weeks
they would have done i guess the racial
cleansing that they desired but i go
well what are you talking about and then
he brings up the fact uh you know as per
mention that you know this is this new
thing called social murder and so this
idea of the fact that if you withhold
trans uh reaffirming i'm using their
words reaffirming surgery you are
leading to the increased suicide rate of
trans kids therefore your actions are
the murderous actions and your choice to
limit is murder and i'm not defending
this i'm i was sitting there mind blown
going
dude and the best part about this is i
got to ask i said when did you start
hormones he goes it saved my life it
saved my life he goes well 22. i go okay
so you're saying that hormone saved your
life at 22. i hope you were past puberty
by 22. so you're a 22 year old you
started taking estrodiol and different
types of blockers and what not at 22.
now you're trying to tell me what a
nine-year-old should be doing buddy did
you see the did you see the article in
the washington post it was an op-ed by
a writer named corinne cohn who was
talking about how
um i don't know what the pronoun is to
use in this case anyway um
corrine was saying that at 19
uh yeah here this is yeah this is the
story tim at 19
um
cohn had uh
was castrated this was intentional um
and then it turns out that actually
he would have been a gay man
and has never had a sexual experience um
when he talked you know talks to friends
and friends are very dismayed by this
and in the in the article corrine talks
about how uh never having experienced
this
you know
they don't really know what they're
missing and i just find this to be so
sad that we are taking
away the sexual futures of so many of
these of these kids
uh not just their reproductive futures
but any real chance at intimacy you know
they're giving up something that they
don't that they don't know they don't
understand
they're giving it up for the rest of
their lives and that's why the way this
is all framed that this is um
you know this is the we're infringing on
the rights of the child no none of these
laws are
restricting the child this is about
restricting you as the adult we're
saying that you that's correct can not
that their rights are being infringed
upon because they're not being mutilated
is is horrific i just want to make one
other point too
elijah brought up the
words and the way that words are
manipulated i think this is really
important because we have to understand
on the other side the same side of this
trans discussion
we are so behind we're playing catch up
right now because the language is so
totally controlled by the left even to
the extent of every time we use the word
gender
we are actually assenting to the left's
framework that's what's correct that
word itself was that was introduced into
the language the way that it's used now
by the people who invented gender
ideology for the purpose of
mainstreaming it so and by a pedophile
specifically john money it's actually
really fascinating too though the whole
language thing because um i was in the
arts for most of my most of my career
most of my adult life and i could see
this you know this starting and you know
artists started becoming arts activists
instead and it started being like oh
when you do when you write a play it
should be um
it should be not just art not just
aesthetic but there needs to be this
activist backbone to it and you could
see people changing the language
intentionally and it started you know we
had the whole pc thing don't say
you know black say african american
don't say
you know i don't know woman say some
other students yeah right like so
but i mean we saw this happen it's been
happening for a long time and at first
just like it is now with the whole
gender thing at first it was sold to us
with the idea of compassion behind it
right it's more compassionate to use
these terms um it makes other people
feel better it's not offensive if you if
you speak about it this way and we have
con consistently allowed ourselves to be
bludgeoned with this idea of the
compassionate way
to talk to people and we're still there
i want to just ask you know uh
it's a legitimate question that i know
will never get answered because the
response on the left will be like it's a
bad faith question
um if if a kid was uh there's general
body dysmorphia dysphoric disorder or
something like that uh i talked about
this on the joe rogan podcast with jack
dorsey if someone and they do they feel
like their fingers need to be removed
they feel like their hand is transabled
this is a thing well this is a thing
yeah it's it's like general body
dysmorphic disorder something like that
would we then say for the health and
safety of the child we will remove their
perfectly functioning hand and the other
question on top of that is
we've seen uh young girls get double
mastectomies at the age of even 13.
uh again i posted this on twitter
there's a study that was done in 2018
looking at the the results of you know
the quality of life
would we give a 13 year old boy large
breast implants if he said that they
would make him feel better and he was
depressed i think overwhelmingly most
parents even parents who want to affirm
their kids they'd probably look at that
and think twice and be like wait a
minute this doesn't seem right because
breast implants are not typically
associated with someone seeking to
like a young boy who's feeling you know
depressed and even a young girl wouldn't
have double d's or something like that
but i'm wondering at what point we
actually start seeing this yeah so
obviously at the present moment the left
would at the very least pretend to be
horrified by the idea of removing a
child's pinky because they've decided
that they don't want to have it at an
early age but if you ask any grown man
what would you rather have happened
would you rather have lost your pinky
finger as a child or would you rather
have lost the ability to fully develop
reproductively as a child any man would
tell you he would rather have lost his
pinky it's not even a question well hold
on there maybe but if you don't go
through puberty you you don't develop
that uh no that's my point well so so
if you ask someone who is has been um
had their gonads removed
this article describes it as gonad
destruction
before the heavy metal band
destruction before before puberty
they're not going to know what they lost
and they're not going to desire things
they haven't developed desire for i
don't know about that i think they'll be
they'll look at healthy married couples
and say i wish i could have had
something like that because there's
nothing i can agree with
this has been you just brought up john
money and this is so we we have a case
study in this and um i was like john
money
did that he's the guy who invented
gender ideology and he did that to a
young
boy a baby baby uh castrated a young boy
um
and told they told the parents to raise
the boy as a girl
and but it didn't the girl identity
didn't take hold because he's not a girl
so eventually they even
switch back yeah even even with hormones
killed himself later in life yeah him
and his brother both and the brother the
bothered and he performed sexual
experiments on the mobile he was a as
well he was a disgusting pervert on
everything this is this is actually an
argument uh the left counters with that
uh it proves gender id uh gender
identity is inherent in a person right
that even though this person who didn't
choose to went through this
later in life they said no i am male and
always was the left argues that
certainly there are people who are who
are born male or female and then later
come to realize they have an alternate
gender identity well what the left i
mean sex is inherent a person does have
a sex gender is a completely nonsensical
term that was first developed by the man
who performed this sick sexual
experiment on children it was a complete
failure but he reported it as a success
it was printed in medical textbooks as
as a success and as a matter of policy
in many hospitals as a result of his
lies many boys who underwent botched
circumcision were transitioned as
infants yeah that was messy yeah and i
i've heard that claim from from the
other side saying oh no the john money
actually proves that we're right but no
that if gender is determined partially
by society and environment and
everything then and that's what john
money believed he's the guy who came up
with this stuff
then this should have worked and it
didn't so he actually disproved
his own theory in this in this horrific
years-long experiment that he ran on
these kids the thing about gender
definition up there i mean
originally gender is a linguistic term
that refers to words like words have
gender masculine or feminine and john
money is the one who said that oh no
people have gender too people have a
gender and a sex yes
but you notice something else because
they said that people have a gender and
a sex and they're two different things
and that's and that's what they went
with for for decades and now they're
kind of collapsing the distinction again
and they're actually they've actually
gotten away from that and now they're
now they're basically saying that gender
and sex are the same thing because a
trans woman is a woman is exactly the
same thing as a woman they will not
allow anymore that a quote trans woman
is um is a male they'll they'll say that
trans woman is a female so they're like
they've gotten rid of the distinction
themselves and they're enshrining this
in law i mean now the the civil rights
act of 1964
protects gender identity in the same way
that it protects you know
women that wasn't that was amended
nationally well it's not like they
haven't gone back and rewritten the
amendment but the executive orders that
biden signed essentially do that well in
uh
most states
have actually passed uh these these
civil rights amendments that say gender
identity is protected as well the
question then is how do you define
gender identity and this is where things
get more difficult in new york for
instance it's defined as a person's
self-expression
because you know i pulled up the word
gender on wikipedia and it says the
range of characteristic characteristics
pertaining to femininity and masculinity
and differentiating between them the
challenges the
modern left ideology suggests that a
dress is not inherently feminine or
masculine in which case it's not a part
of gender so if you have somebody who
has long hair and wears makeup and you
know wears bras and female clothing that
isn't according to their own ideology
inherently feminine and gendered in
which case
the whole thing starts to become
illogical i suppose
how does how does a child know they're
transgender if a little girl says she
likes playing with trucks and the color
blue
they might say will you like things boys
like no because girls can like trucks in
the color blue same as well they're
trying to have it both ways they're both
telling us that gender stereotypes are a
problem and need to be abolished and
that you can tell what your gender
identity is based on which gender
stereotypes you adhere to
and both things can't be true i i really
do think that um for the most part it's
not that they're trying to have both
technically it's the case it's that
there is no truth but power to these
people so any circumstance in which they
can assert something to gain power they
do and that's why they often contradict
themselves then we sit here as logical
beings trying to understand the map
they've created in terms of logic and it
makes no sense to us yeah in breaking
down sexual boundaries is fantastic if
you're in a position of power and rather
than having a healthy functioning
society you'd rather have one where
people look up to and they're very easy
to control and the best way to break
down sex relationships the best way to
break uh break down the family after
you've already done things like uh made
contraceptives widely available and
socially acceptable is to go for the
actual direct definition of sexuality
and completely collapse it so that the
sexes have no hope of ever developing
any understanding of how they should
relate to each other from their society
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time